und wir haben
Tagesordnungspunkte angekommen weswegen
sich heute hier die AFD trifft zwar geht
es um Vorschläge zur Wahl des ersten
Listenplatzes der Europawahl die AFD
möchte ihren Spitzenkandidaten küren
zwei Vorschläge gibt es zur Zeit
Maximilian Krah und Andreas Otti wurden
vorgeschlagen
sich hier zu bewerben
wir haben in dem Verfahrensantrag zuerst
natürlich zu befragen ob die Kandidaten
überhaupt bereitstehen bevor wir eine
Liste hier schließen also ich darf jetzt
die vorgeschlagenen Kandidaten bitten
sich an einem der Mikrofone einzuführen
die Frage in der Reihenfolge wie sie
vorgeschlagen wurden zuerst Herr Dr
Maximilian Kram ob er
zur Kandidatur steht
bereit vielen Dank steht bereit
und ja Otti ich stehe bereit danke steht
ebenfalls bereit
so vielen Dank dann können wir jetzt die
Kandidatenliste
schließen wenn sich keine weiteren
Vorschläge ergeben weitere Vorschläge
kann ich nicht erkennen dann darf ich
sie jetzt darum bitten die
Kandidatenliste zu schließen mit der
blauen Stimmkarte
blaue Stimmkarte zum Schließen der
Kandidatenliste rote Stimmkarte wäre das
noch nicht möchte
Enthaltungen dann stelle ich fest dass
die Kandidatenliste für den Listenplatz
1 geschlossen ist
so wir lösen jetzt die
vorstellungsreihenfolge aus
zuerst darf sich vorstellen
Herr Otti
und danach folgerichtig Herr Dr Graf
ich darf einmal noch mal darauf
hinweisen für beide Kandidaten und alle
folgenden dass das Formular mit dem
beschlossenen Fragen vorne vorliegt das
sollten sie auf jeden Fall ausfüllen
damit die Antwort auf die Fragen an die
Wand geworfen werden können
weiterhin haben sie wie alle anderen
Kandidaten auch die Möglichkeit
hier ein polizeiliche Führungszeugnis
das Führungszeugnis sowie die Erklärung
nach Paragraph 19 der bundesratsung
vorne im Vorfeld auch schon einzureichen
das muss nicht auf letzten Drücker
erfolgen
zwei Kandidaten gibt es nur für den
Platz der Spitzenkandidaten für die
Europawahl Andreas Otti Mitglied der AFD
in Berlin Spandau seit 2015 auch
Bezirksvorsitzender vorher nach eigenen
Angaben 20 Jahre Mitglied der CSU und
dann tritt noch Maximilian Kra an der
Name wurde schon im Vorfeld hier
gehandelt unter anderem weil er die
Unterstützung von Björn höcke genießt
aus dem Landesverband Sachsen ist schon
im Mitglied im Europäischen
Parlament und die beiden füllen jetzt
die Fragen aus auf die sich vorher
geeinigt wurde unter anderem eben ob sie
Englisch sprechen und wo sie Berufs wie
viele Jahre Berufserfahrung sie haben
dann haben beide jeweils 7 Minuten Zeit
sich vorzustellen werden dann noch zwei
Fragen beantworten
um damit die Delegierten hier
entscheiden können
welche Person die AFD
repräsentiert im Europawahlkampf 2024
anmelden können indem sie ihren
Mitgliedsausweis hier vorne am
antragstisch in die Urne einwerfen sie
können dies auch noch unmittelbar nach
Ende der Regel tun wir werden immer
einmal schauen ob noch jemand mit einer
Frage Anmeldung unterwegs ist und dann
nehmen wir die Auslosung der
Fragesteller vor
insoweit sie gestern da waren alles
genauso wie gestern was diesen Punkt
anbetrifft
so und ich kann hier schon lesen wie
Andreas Otti die Fragen beantwortet hat
das wird hier schriftlich gemacht
mir ist nicht ganz klar warum das nicht
mündlich gemacht wird dann wäre es etwas
schneller und so trage ich Ihnen das für
er ist seit 2014 in der Partei ist der
englischen Sprache nach eigenen Angaben
mächtig verfügt über ein abgeschlossener
Berufsausbildung oder ein
abgeschlossenes Studium und hat 28 Jahre
Berufserfahrung außerhalb der Politik
38 Kartoffeln die Versammlung ist das
für jedermann lesbar
was dort an der Tafel steht
geht das irgendwie vielleicht größer
Frage an die Technik die Schrift
so meine Damen und Herren wir machen
jetzt einmal kurz einen kurzes
Stimmungstest und zwar ob die Antwort
auf die Fragen ob das für jedermann
lesbar wenn Sie das was dort oben jetzt
projiziert ist vernünftig lesen können
dann bitte ich Sie einmal um die blaue
Stimmkarte
das ersetzt auch das nächste
augenärztliche Test hier heute so blaue
Stimmkarte wenn Sie das lesen können
rote Stimmkarte wäre das nicht lesen
kann was dort jetzt projiziert ist
1 2 3
einzelne
und das ist natürlich spannend ob jetzt
auf die einzelnen Rücksicht genommen
wird oder man sagt das sind nur einzelne
dann machen wir die Schriftart nicht
größer aber jetzt ist sie hier schon ein
bisschen größer eingestellt
es sind ein paar Worte ich glaube es
wäre doch ein wenig schneller gewesen
wenn die Kandidaten das einfach mündlich
beantwortet hätten aber die Delegierten
haben es so beschlossen dass diese
Fragen auch schriftlich beantwortet
werden
sollen eine sehr geringe Anzahl von
Personen die sagten sie können das nicht
ordentlich lesen wenn Sie wünschen dass
wir das Vorlesen dann müssten sie das
beantragen und dann könnte darüber
abgestimmt werden wenn er den Antrag
nicht kommt dann geben wir davon aus
dass sie es organisiert bekommen im
Laufe der vorstellungszeit einmal sich
das Ganze durch einen Ausfallschritt
oder dergleichen dann doch ins Sichtfeld
zu bekommen
wenn ein Antrag gestellt werden wollte
müsste er jetzt gestellt werden weil wir
im Laufe des Tages ansonsten wird keine
Veränderung mehr am Verfahren vornehmen
können ohne weiteres
ich sehe nicht dass an solcher Antrag
jetzt kommt dann beginnen wir und zuerst
erhält die Gelegenheit zur Vorstellung
Herr Otti die Fragen auf die beschlossen
sind sind projiziert
so schönen guten Tag Herr Otti ich
stelle erst einmal fest dass uns von
innen und Sie können einmal kurz sagen
ob das zutreffen ist kein aktuelles
Führungszeugnis vorliegt und auch keine
Erklärung nach Paragraph 19
wenn das zutreffend ist dann haben Sie
jetzt bis zu 7 Minuten Zeit für Ihre
Vorstellung bitte schön
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren deliierte
ich bin Andreas Otti leidenschaftlicher
Staatsbürger Familienvater Ehemann
Berufsoffizier mit jetzt noch etwas über
einem Jahr Dienstzeit
über 20 Jahre CSU-Mitglied im
bayerischen Oberland und Allgäu
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD im Rathaus
Berlin Spandau und Bezirksvorsitzender
seit nun fast schon acht Jahre 30 Jahre
Europa-Union glauben Sie mir deshalb
dass ich mich in Europa und gerade in
der den Schmiede des großen Europas auch
auf super nationale Ebene auch mit Blick
auf kuttendorf die bestens zu Recht
finde fünf Jahre Wahlbeamter in der
Exekutive für die AFD als
Bezirksstadtrat und Abteilungsleiter für
das staatliche Hochbauamt und für das
Umwelt und naturschutzamt übrigens ohne
Abwahl Antrag und missbilligungsnote der
Blockparteien Führungserfahrung mit bis
zu 200 Mitarbeitern
auf nach Europa Europas das Land der
unterschiedlichen Sprachen der
unterschiedlichen Münzen der
unterschiedlichen Kulturen ja es ist das
Land der unterschiedlichen Mentalitäten
und verschiedenster Schönheiten das
italienische sächsische ungarische oder
badische schöne ist als solches immer
zweifelsfrei meistens bevor man darüber
nachdenkt so identifizieren das soll
sich ändern geht es nach den
herrschenden mit
korruptionshintergrund
supranationaler Glas Paläste
resettenment statt Nachfragen nach einer
bedarfsorientierten Zuwanderung in die
europäischen Vaterländer
die Gedanken sind frei das steht heute
bereits zu Disposition liebe Freunde
kritische Stimmen zu Massenmigration zur
LGBT Lobby oder die Verurteilung und
Verteidigung viel mehr das ungeborenen
Lebens sollen unter die supernationale
Fall bei den Maschine geehrt werden
über den Weg der Implementierung völlig
ihrer Fantasien soll den Völkern Denker
ausgemacht werden es gibt folgerichtig
keinen vernünftigen Grund als Deutscher
AFD Einzelgänger durch die europäische
Legislaturperiode zu wandern wir die
über 400 Millionen Europäer haben
identische Gefahrenlagen in den
jeweiligen Ländern der
supernationalstaat ist hier bitte hören
Sie es aufmerksam Gefahr nicht Lösung
das sage ich Ihnen als überzeugter
Europäer
ich trete für den europäischen
Wettbewerb ein dragis Italian first ist
mir insofern eine akzeptable
Ausgangslage als dass er bitte sein Ziel
alles für Italien zuerst aus eigener
Kraft und bitte nicht auf den Schultern
deutscher erreichen möge
wie oft sage ich nicht mehr was ich
denke diese Frage stellen sich Familien
Männer und Frauen Mädchen und Jungen
aller europäischen Völker es ist
vielleicht sogar die Schicksalsfrage auf
dem Weg zur traurigen Nachtvorstellung
Europas stirbt und damit stirbt auch die
innere Freiheit der Völker das
Bekenntnis zur Oligarchie exklusiver
korrupter Minderheiten ist längst
moralisches pflichttor in Brüssel und
Straßburg traurige Statisten in dieser
düsteren Nachtvorstellung sind die
Deutschen Abgeordnete liebe Freunde der
Altparteien
deshalb sind sie uns Widersacher und
zwar ganz grundlegend und fundamental es
ist dort so wie bei uns in Berlin da
holt sich der Regierende Bürgermeister
Kai Wegner eine selbst ernannte
afd-jägerin aus dem müller-staat Iran
als innensenatorin und muss sich nun von
einem
opportunistischen black Rocker Friedrich
Merz etwas von kommunaler Zusammenarbeit
mit der AFD erzählen lassen die Frau
sollte wissen wie es in ihrem Heimatland
um die freie Sprache bestellt ist wo die
Sittenpolizei täglich die Freiheit
niederprügelt
während die CDU gebetsmühlenartig die
regionale Selbstverantwortung liebe
Freunde in Europa beschwört wird der
Kollege Robert Sesselmann einem
demokratiecheck unterzogen ist das die
Selbstbestimmung nach europäischer
cdu-rezeptur ja sie ist es sie können
einen Kreis und einen Dreieck so oft
aufeinander legen wie Sie wollen es wird
nie passen so ist es mit Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und den Begriff der Nation
deshalb werde ich
wirkmächtig dort hat anlegen wo
Anpassungen notwendig sind und dabei
gerne auch Widerstände brechen wo die X
für u-fraktion seit Jahren nationale
Interessen schändlich verraten hat denn
Sozialstaatlichkeit die wir Freunde ist
nur praktizierbar innerhalb der
Staatsgrenzen für ein Staatsvolk und in
rechtsstaatlichen Rahmen wie oft sage
ich nicht was ich denke man beschwert
sich bei mir dass ich zu sehr den Opfern
des ukrainischen Volkes meine
trauerschenke man tritt aber auch immer
klagen an mich heran dass ich kein
schlechtes Wort über die einfachen
gefallenen russischen Soldaten zu sagen
bereit sei der einfache russische Soldat
stammt nicht aus den Vororten Moskau und
auch nicht aus den Willen Vierteln St
Petersburg liebe Freunde es sind die
armen Söhne aus dem weiten Hinterland
ihr Blut bringen müssen die Ukraine hat
die exe regierungswelle hinter sich die
Bruder Völker bluten aus
das ist nicht in meinem Interesse und
auch nicht im Interesse Europas und ich
bin mir sicher dass hier im Saal eine
große Mehrheit sich hinter diese
Position zu verstellen stellen vermag
ziel ist eine Friedensordnung und eine
sicherheitsaktiektur in zunächst
deutschen Interesse und das weltweit
aufrichtig sein liebe Freunde spielt in
Europa eine entscheidende Rolle wollen
sie der Korruption die Stirn bieten weil
ich mir sicher bin dass sie mich nach
mandatsträgerabgaben Fragen werde ich
werde die Zahlen und werde pro Monat
3000 Euro an die AFD abtreten sind
36.000 € im Jahr das ist auch nach
postmathematischer Zählweise mehr als
die satzungskonform 733 Euro
. die beste Medizin gegen Kooperation
ist nämlich liebe Freunde Haltung
ich stehe auch auf keiner Liste fremder
Konzerne weil das ein Schlag ins Gesicht
der deutschen Unternehmer ist in diesem
Sinne darf ich mich Ihnen herzlich
empfehlen semper Kommunist ich bin der
Andreas Otti vielen herzlichen Dank
die erste Vorstellung hier auf der
europawahlversammlung der AFD von
Andreas Otti und nun dürfen noch zwei
Fragen gestellt werden Otti es gibt
jetzt die Möglichkeit dem Kandidaten
Fragen zu stellen wenn noch jemand eine
Frage anmelden möchte kann er dies tun
müsste dann jetzt sicher nach vorne
begeben und dort sein Mitgliedsausweis
oder eine andere Karte im
Scheckkartenformat einwerfen
Plastikkarte
sehen nicht dass noch jemand unterwegs
wäre dann bitte ich darum dass uns die
Urne mit den
Karten gebracht wird dass wir die
Fragesteller auslosen können
zwei Fragen sind beschlossen
Fragezeichen seit 30 Sekunden Antwort
seit 60 Sekunden
die erste Frage kommt von Frank
Schermesser
und die zweite von Andreas Joker
so bitte an eins der seine Mikrofone
kommen Herr Schermesser am roten sein
Mikrofon für 30 Sekunden bitte schön ja
Frank schirmitzer Landesverband Berlin
Andreas du bist Berufssoldat kannst du
uns noch etwas ausführlichere Ausführung
machen zum
europäischen sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik was hast du dir da
vorgestellt
ja meine lieben Dank für die Frage im
Grunde genommen ist es ein
internationales Konzert deutsche
Streitkräfte müssen über
all entsetzbar sein verstehen sie mir
nicht falsch sie sollen es nicht ständig
und dauernd im Auftrag einer vollkommen
konfusen Bundesregierung aber gleichwohl
müssen wir Streitkräfte auf einem sehr
hohen standhalten wir sehen dass die
Bundeswehr in diesen Tagen und in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten
Außergewöhnliches geleistet hat die
Luftwaffe ist in den innovativen Raum
verlegt in einer rekordverlegezeit haben
wir gezeigt hat die Luftwaffe gezeigt
was sie kann die Männer und Frauen der
Streitkräfte benötigen Ihre
Unterstützung und deshalb ist es ganz
wichtig dass auch nicht unterschwellig
irgendwie der anscheinend entsteht man
wolle diese so wichtigen Streitkräfte es
war früher mal die Schule der Nationen
abschaffen Deutschland ist nukius der
sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik
wenn wir das nur wollen weltweit
weltweit heißt deutsche See und
Handelswege und ich darf sagen als
überzeugter Europäer europäische See und
Handelswege müssen natürlich zu schützen
sein vielen Dank
ja bitteschön
dann kommt die zweite Frage von Herrn
Joker am blauen salmikrofon bitteschön
für 30 Sekunden ja meine Frage wäre sind
sie eigentlich also ich um es ich muss
ein bisschen umformulieren
finden Sie nicht dass der
Spitzenkandidat der AFD ein Mindestmaß
an Bekanntheit braucht oder zumindest
mal irgendwo bekannt sein sollte
zumindest in der parteilich dass man
naja
auf diese Frage will ich gerne antworten
aber ich gehe davon aus dass die
anwesenden Delegierten natürlich einen
Grund Respekt in sich tragen der im
Grunde genommen ein Stück weit die
gestanden ist mir Ihre Frage
überkündigt ich habe ihren Namen jetzt
nicht verstanden das macht nichts ich
kenne sie auch nicht das macht aber auch
nicht ich will aber trotz alledem auf
ihre Frage antworten so ich stehe seit
vielen Jahren für dieses Land als
Berufssoldat und auch in der Zeit in der
Union war es mir wichtig ja sie können
gerne weggehen bitte hören Sie aber
weiter zu dass ich mit Geist und auch
mit körperlichen Einsatz mich für diese
für dieses Land im Grunde genommen
bereitgestellt habe und wenn sie
einigermaßen die Presse verfolgt haben
werden Sie sehen dass ich 2016 der erste
Mann in Berlin mit zwei wichtigen
Ressorts in der Exekutive war wenn Sie
das als unwichtig deklarieren dann haben
sie Politik nicht im Ansatz verstanden
aber ich bin gerne bereit in bilateralen
Gesprächen vielen herzlichen Dank
dann sind und das war es dann schon als
gibt hier nicht viel Zeit für die
Entscheidungsfindung mit zwei Fragen
dürfen gestellt werden und
trotz der Anmerkung hier das Andreas
Otti in ein Partei bisher auf
bundesebenen nicht so sehr in
Erscheinung getreten es gab es doch
recht viel Applaus für seine Antwort und
Vorstellung einmal bitte auch die
Antworten einblenden auf die
pflichtfrage
und auch das trage ich gerne ihnen vor
seit zwei
Tausch 16 also wurde es zuerst
eingezahlt ist Maximilian K in der AFD
jetzt gerade ist hier noch die andere
Folie eingeblendet jetzt sind wir wieder
dabei
Maximilian Krage gewesen seit 2016
ist er in der AFD ist der englischen
Sprache mächtig verfügt über eine
Berufsausbildung oder ein Studium und
sagt er hätte 14 Jahre Berufserfahrung
plus zwei Jahre referend Freunde wir
liegen bei 22 Prozent wir haben uns
innerhalb eines Jahres mehr als
verdoppelt und eins ist klar damit sind
wir nicht zufrieden sondern wir wollen
ganz Deutschland zu einem großen
Sonneberg machen und
damit wir das schaffen müssen wir den
Kurs halten den wir letztes Jahr in
Riesa begonnen haben wir müssen Kurs
halten weil das hat uns zum Erfolg
geführt und ich kann eins sagen wir sind
mittlerweile die spannendste
Rechtsparteien ganz Europa überall
überall hat man den Leuten nämlich
erzählt man muss sich anpassen wenn man
Erfolg sein will man muss so eine Art
werteunion sein und gar keine echte
Alternative aber die Wahrheit für die
wir stehen heißt es nein wir wollen
nicht eine Partei des Tanks des Streits
und der taktischen Spielchen sein
sondern wir wollen eine Alternative sein
der Leidenschaft der Mut und des
Patriotismus dafür kriegt man Prozente
und ja es ist kein leichter Gang für
mich hier auf dieses Podium gewesen denn
die Verlierer aus Riesa haben ja das was
sie an Argumenten nicht aufbringen
können in den letzten Monaten in Schmutz
investiert
und trotzdem
denke ich dass man sich jeder überlegen
muss ob es nicht Ihnen auch selbst
treffen kann ihr auch tretet für Ämter
an ihr selbst kandidiert wollt ihr in
Zukunft
Opfer von solchen monatelangen anonymen
Schmutzkampagnen sein wie es bei mir war
oder ist es nicht an der Zeit heute den
Dreck werfen endlich mal die rote Karte
zu zeigen dass wir uns nach vorne
bewegen können
[Applaus]
der liebe Freunde deutschland braucht
eine Alternative für Deutschland und
nicht eine Alternative die sich mit sich
selbst beschäftigt wir haben Wähler den
es existenziell an ihn an die an das
Eingemachte geht wir haben die
Verkäuferin die ihre Nachzahlung nicht
stemmen kann wir haben die Familie die
ihren Kühlschrank am Monatsende noch
voll haben will und den Polizeibeamten
der überlegt wir den Sprit bezahlt für
die Nachtschicht diese Leute erwarten
von uns Leistung sie erwarten von uns
Einigkeit und sie haben kein Verständnis
für irgendwelche Spielereien weil man
nicht einsehen will das in Riesa die
richtigen gewonnen haben und das sind
wir hier im Saal liebe Freunde
ich bin
ich bin das so in einer Sonderschule
Lehrerin
ich habe meine Mutter oft abgeholt und
weil sie noch gearbeitet hat hat sie
mich die Ganztagsbetreuung mitgeschickt
ich weiß was Armut in diesem Land
bedeutet auch wenn sie mich Gott sei
Dank nicht selbst betroffen hat es sind
Kinder die aus der rütteten
Verhältnissen kommen und es gibt viele
Verhältnisse in einem Land mit
kultureller linker Hegemonie
diese Kinder muss man fördern damit sie
ihr kleines Glück schaffen können und
mittlerweile haben wir auch in Sachsen
an den sonderernden Hauptschulen über 50
Prozent Migranten es wird nicht mehr
unterrichtet und die Kinder haben Angst
vor den Pausen
der große deutsche Philosoph Dieter
Bohlen hat mal gesagt das Problem
besteht darin dass die dummen nicht
erkennen dass sie dumm sind es gibt
liebe Freunde
an deutschen Sonderschulen keine dummen
Menschen aber vergleichen Sie das mal
mit einem grünen Parteitag und
und wir sind die Partei die denen die
arbeiten wollen die hart arbeiten die
darum betrogen werden weil man von ihrem
brutto alles ausgeht für Klima für
Gender für Einwanderung und für Krieg
die würde zurückgeben ihr netto
zurückgeben und den wir zurufen ihr seid
nicht vergessen es gibt keine
vergessenen Männer und Frauen für die
AFD wir stehen zusammen denn wir sind
ein Volk egal ob wir dafür angegriffen
werden das macht uns stark
liebe Freunde wir sind ein Volk weil
wenn wir uns unsere Familienalben zeigen
dann erkennen wir das schon unsere
Großväter und ihre unsere Urgroßväter
ein Volk sind wir sprechen dieselbe
Sprache wir fühlen und denken in
denselben Worten uns wurden dieselben
Märchen vorgelesen und dieselben Lieder
vorgesungen und wenn den sozial
Schwachen unter uns was auch nach der
kulturellen linken Hegemonie leider die
Regel ist keine Märchen mehr vorgelesen
und keine Lieder mehr vorgesungen würden
so wissen wir doch ihr Herz würde tanzen
wenn es deutsche Märchen und deutsche
Lieder werden wie man den vorträgt
und deshalb wird hier überhaupt wie man
sich verstecken wir gehen stolz und
erhobenen Hauptes nach Brüssel und wir
wissen wir haben Freunde wir haben hier
gestern fantastische reden gehört also
bei dem Kollegen aus Bulgarien muss ich
ja sagen mein lieber Schwan da können
wir uns noch mal Mut und Leidenschaft
abschauen da wird es so weit kommen wir
wollen mit diesen Partnern
zusammenarbeiten wir stehen zur Idee und
wir werden aus dieser Idee eine Idee
plus machen mit den neuen Kräften die
sich hier bei uns vorgestellt und von
euch durch eure Applaus und eure
Standing Ovations ihre Unterstützung
bekommen haben wir werden das was wir in
Riesa angefangen haben dass wir jetzt
das öffentliche Leben in Deutschland
dominieren dass da hinten die Presse ist
dass alles weil und Kinoprogramm
das war endlich wieder hört was wir
sagen
tragen nach Brüssel und nach Straßburg
liebe Freunde wir setzen heute fort die
Entscheidung die wir vor einem Jahr
getroffen haben die Entscheidung für
eine Alternative auf die wir stolz sind
wo wir gern Mitglied sind weil wir
endlich was zu sagen haben weil wir
endlich kämpfen und weil wir endlich
nach vorne gehen von hier und heute muss
ein Signal ausgehen das Signal der
Erneuerung das Signal der Kraft das
Signal der Leidenschaft und des
Patriotismus wenn wir es schaffen
Deutschlands Herz zu erobern wird es ein
neues Europa geben ein besseres Europa
eins das allen partnervölkern wieder
Heimat sein kann lasst uns mutig sein
lasst uns kämpfen stehen wir zu unserer
Leidenschaft und lasst uns gemeinsam den
Weg voranschreiten vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ja der sich hier vorstellt zuerst auch
die Anschuldigungen eingegangen ist dass
er eine Ausschreibung
undurchsichtig durchgeführt hätte diese
Anschuldigung hatte hier einen Schmutz
gezeichnet
schon länger Verwerfungen zwischen den
Abgeordneten in Europäischen Parlament
vielen Dank Herr Kram
wir haben dann jetzt die noch die
Gelegenheit Fragen anzumelden ist noch
jemand unterwegs der noch eine Frage
einwerfen möchte oder die Frage
Anmeldung
das kann ich
noch eine Frage Anmeldung hier
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann kommen
wir zur Auslosung der Fragesteller
so 6 aus 49
die erste Frage kommt von Michael
winterich
und die zweite Frage von Lothar Bleker
Herr winterich für 30 Sekunden an einem
der wahlmikrofone Bitte einfinden
so das ist das rote sein Mikrofon 30
Sekunden für Ihre Frage bitte schön ja
klar wir haben gestern den Beitritt zur
Idee Fraktion beschlossen ich möchte
gerne wissen wie sie dazu stehen was sie
für Konzept mit der Idee Fraktion hätten
beschlossen ich stehe dazu dass wir in
Europa nur etwas erreichen können mit
Zusammenarbeit und wir sind in einem
sehr sehr starken Team in einem sehr
sehr starken Club bevor ich hierher
gekommen bin war ich noch mal im ROM
beim Parlamentspräsidenten Lorenzo
Fontana der Mitglied der Lega ist der
hat mir gesagt er bekommt viel Druck
über die CDU und die Regierung mit uns
nicht zusammen zu arbeiten aber wir
könne uns allen eins ausrichten eine
Kraft die in Deutschland über 20 Prozent
hat kann und werde man nicht ignorieren
und liebe Freunde
bisher
genau dafür
dass wir mit diesen starken Partnern
zusammenarbeiten und immer auch schauen
wer neu dazukommt wir müssen noch
stärker werden in Deutschland und euweit
und genau das setzen wir fort insofern
war der Beitritt zur idee-partei ein
richtiger und logischer Schritt wir
wollen in der Idee Fraktion bleiben wir
wollen dass Sie größer wird und wir
wollen dass wir so stark werden dass man
in der nächsten parlamentsession nicht
mehr gegen uns so einen Cordon Sanitär
machen kann sondern dass wir mit
entscheiden vielen Dank
dann kommt die zweite Frage von Herrn
Bleker ebenfalls am roten salmikrofon
für 30 Sekunden bitteschön ja guten Tag
mein Name ist Uta blika ich komme aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen wo ich in der
Kommunalpolitik aktiv benutzt man darf
Träger in der Stadt auf kreist auf LVR
Ebene meine Frage geht dahin sehen Sie
eine mögliche
Schnittmenge zwischen ihrer Arbeit auf
super nationaler Ebene und unserer
Kommunalpolitik jeweils vor Ort vielen
Dank also vielen Dank die Schnittmenge
sehe ich leider weil ich befürchte dass
sie überhaupt nicht mehr im Rahmen Ihrer
kommunalen Selbstverwaltung die Freiheit
haben sich selbst zu verwalten sie sind
in einem derartigen Maße durch
EU-Regulierung überreguliert dass wir in
die Freiheit nehmen alles wo sie
Fördergeldern Anspruch nehmen kriegen
sie ja so viel Auflagen dass sie gar
nicht mehr selbst entscheiden können das
heißt wir haben die städtenmengen aber
es muss unser Ziel sein diese
Schnittmengen so weit zu verringern dass
sie endlich wieder die Luft haben frei
in ihrer Gemeinde das Beste für ihre
Mitbürger zu schaffen von daher ganz
klar weniger EU ist mehr Europa
vielen Dank dann waren auch das zwei
Fragen und zwei Antworten und dann ist
der Kandidat harte Maximilian Glück mit
den Fragen keine Frage zu seiner
Suspendierung
aus der Idee Fraktion keine Fragen auch
zu den Vorwürfen dass er
die Fraktion im Europaparlament nicht
stärken wolle das wurde ihm vorgeworfen
aber nicht hier auf der
europa-versammlung der AFD
ja jetzt höre ich gerade das muss das
Ergebnis jetzt sein für den
Spitzenkandidaten der AFD für die Wahl
zum Europäischen Parlament
so geht um unseren Spitzenkandidaten zur
Europawahl 2024 und dann darf ich die
Technik bitten dass er Ergebnis
einzublenden
und stelle fest dass auf Doktor
ein Ergebnis das muss kann mit
eingeblendet werden
und stelle fest auf Andreas Otti
sind entfallen 142 Stimmen auf den
Kandidaten maximierend dr Maximilian
370 Stimmen in 51 nein stimmt acht
Enthaltungen mit 65,7% gewählt
vorbereitet dr Maximilian Graf
Herr DRK ich darf sie fragen ob sie die
Wahl auch annehmen ich nehme natürlich
an und ich bin unglaublich glücklich
auch weil ihr wisst wie schwer es in den
letzten Monaten war und jeder der heute
gesagt hat wir vertrauen der hat nicht
nur eine Entscheidung getroffen sondern
wenn man jeden Tag mit Dreck geworfen
wird ihr wisst nicht wie gut es tut
Freunde zu haben also vielen lieben Dank
und jetzt mit voller Kraft in diesen
Wahl das ist die beste
bundesweite werden
[Musik]
ja Herr Dr Karl
herzlichen Glückwunsch ausrichten und
einen guten wahlkampfspitzenkandidaten
schon einmal wünschen
an dieser Stelle habe ich den
unterliegenden Kandidaten den Herrn Otti
zu fragen ob er für Listenplatz 2 erneut
antritt dazu möge er sich bitte an einem
Mikrofon erklären
Andreas werden
[Musik]